I want to build a team of some bad
people can do some good what are you
really up to flag doesn't need to know
all you need to knows you work for me
you need real soldiers not these scum
bag everyone has a weakness and a
weakness can be leveraged that is just a
mean lady yeah
you got a job to do it on
getting people to act against their own
self-interest it's what I do for later
I'll accept the consequences I am your
consequence
they worried about you didn't believe
the stories nobody does ja boys to book
the door only my friends call me Floyd
anyone got no friends Floyd loaf hello
he's got a little bit sketchy in their
toenails everything in growing felonies
one day I'm gonna get out of here and
I'm gonna rain down on you you just
threaten us staff member do something
why don't we have some fun
this is the deal you disobey me you got
distract me
he destroyed me I love they told you but
I'm a hit man
I'll save
but you build in moist and stockyards I
want to see stop
oh I was just trying to get you there no
hard feelings right we good
hey youtubers is charlie so there's a
new Amanda Waller trailer for Suicide
Squad the worst one of them all it just
chose Amanda Waller basically like the
most terrible human being on the planet
so let's break it down so there's
actually quite a bit of new footage in
here I just I love the idea that it says
burn after use on Harley's t-shirt here
you just start daydreaming about what
she might be doing in that cell that
will require them to burn her prison
uniform but if you weren't familiar like
I love the graphics on all these
trailers like they have a really awesome
color scheme in the way they're
promoting the movie but Belle Reve here
like it's really awesome logo but Belle
Reve is the original prison from the
John Australia Suicide Squad comic so
like even though Harley Quinn didn't
join the Suicide Squad to the last ten
years or so most of this is inspired by
the classic John aw strander comic so
it's like a super deep cut but as you
can imagine this trailer just meant to
highlight the idea that Amanda Waller is
the most dangerous mean person on the
squad technically she's a suicide squad
member even though she's the one that
put the team together Viola Davis is
terrifying performance of course totally
makes you believe it if you're not super
familiar with her she does this TV show
called how to get away with murder and
she plays a very Amanda Waller type
character very complex not really good
character not really an evil character
someone that does very terrible things
to accomplish their goals Rick Flagg
might be leading the team but he's just
basically the spec ops guy that Amanda
Waller uses his her finger puppet to put
the team together but it's not like
they're best friends or anything like
that there's no love lost between them
one of the funny things she said about
when they were filming the movie like
when she was filming scenes with Rick
Flagg is that David Ayer would tell her
to just randomly cuss out Joel Kinnaman
who's playing the Rick Flagg character
without him knowing about it like
changed lines on the flat like usually
when they film scenes they have like a
set amount of pages that they're gonna
do from the script like okay we're gonna
film these lines this is gonna be this
scene so to kind of bring out the tone
of the relationship that he was looking
for in the movie he would have Viola
Davis ad lib and call Joel Kinnaman like
a [ __ ] and see it's like what are you a
[ __ ] what's the matter with you are you
afraid to do that you know like are you
afraid to put this team together you
afraid to go on this mission and he
would get so pissed off but it was
exactly what David Ayer was looking for
in those scenes like you hear about the
crazy things the directors do with their
act
to get what they want out of scenes like
okay you know you're not really bringing
the emotion that I'm looking for so like
they'll play mind games sometimes not in
a malicious way but just to get the
performance that they need out of the
actors so like out of all these actors i
would say Viola Davis is probably the
most pro so you could go to her as a
director and be like okay so I want Rick
Flagg to just be absolutely pissed off
with Amanda Waller so what I'm gonna
have you do in this scene is that you
have this dialogue that you guys are
filming I'm gonna have you changed this
and just make fun of him randomly just
call him a [ __ ] just call him names
make him feel inadequate so he's gonna
get really pissed off and it's going to
make the scene that much better so
whenever you go see the movie and you
see characters within the team and
characters talking to Amanda Waller get
really pissed up like like really
hardcore scenes try to imagine what
David AR said off-screen to those actors
before they film the scene to get them
so worked up it's just hilarious
especially if you've ever been on a film
set because the minute that they call
cut the actors just drop it there just
like a couple of pros I don't think that
anybody that was filming this besides
Jared Leto is an actual method actor so
whenever cameras stop rolling you know
typical actors superpro just completely
drop whatever energy their character has
like even if they're a little worked up
it might take them a sec like a Batman
is fighting racial cool like the minute
the scene breaks Christian Bale and Liam
Neeson could hug each other and just be
completely fine with it most of you who
have read any kind of story know all
about Amanda Waller you know the drill
really she walks away seeming like the
main villain like The Suicide Squad are
a bunch of villains that they team up
because they're expendable they send him
to take down whatever the big bad is of
the film like the Joker isn't the big
bad of this film he's just another
villain that shows up it just tries to
cause a bunch of chaos in his pursuit of
Harley Quinn but there's an actual
mystical threat to the Suicide Squad are
trying to take down in midway city in
this film but Amanda Waller will
probably walk away from the film seeming
like the actual big villain it's just a
narrative device with the characters to
make the villain like the Suicide Squad
themselves seem like the protagonist
even though they are terrible people so
Viola Davis is going to be so fantastic
at being an [ __ ] that she's going to
make all these [ __ ] look like Clark
Kent by comparison so they're going to
be hyping the [ __ ] out of the movie
Comic Con I'll be doing all kinds of
videos for everything I just
Suicide Squad but everything else like
Wonder Woman there'll be some new
footage for everything so be sure to
subscribe to get that and there is a new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video now this is like
the DC giveaway I'm talking about
they'll be like a Marvel giveaway Game
of Thrones so just pay attention
whenever I post videos for different
things from different studios so what's
going to happen Wednesday is is I'll
post like my last scheduled video that
will explain when everything is
happening when stuff is going to drop
when i'm going to be posting videos so
look out for that but there's a new
batman telltale trailer then i'm going
to post next so if you haven't played a
telltale Game before it's almost like
playing a video game that's a visual
novel so there's like this Batman story
and it's kind of like reading a comic
book that's really a video game so it's
very cutscene heavy the voice actors are
really good it's going to involve a lot
of Batman's classic villain so I'm just
I'm really excited to see Telltale's
spin on the Batman mythos so that will
post in a couple hours and the really
cool thing is is because it's something
that I talk about all the time I am
totally gonna do Batman telltale Game
play games on my game channel so just
look out for that it's gonna be a little
while before that stuff comes well you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for all my DC comic con
previews and you can click here for my
breakdown of the star wars episode 8
preview they did its star wars
celebration this weekend thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you